Where I grew up, the words Millennium Force,
Raptor, Mean Streak, Mantis, Magnum, Demon
Drop and Power Tower were thrown around every
spring and summer.
All of them give you the thrilling sensation
of plummeting to your death!
So why did we ride all those rides?
Roller coasters are the crown jewel of amusement
parks.
There are whole industries vying for the title
of tallest, fastest, steepest, loopest, largest
or bad-assest coaster around.
Its history can be traced back to 1750, an
ice-slide was constructed in St. Petersburg
Russia to provide thrills for sledders.
In 1804, a visiting Frenchman copied the idea
in Paris using rails and wheels instead of
sleds; and boom the roller coaster slid into
the world consciousness.Today, there are over
3600 coasters on the planet according to the
Roller Coaster Database, and the 418-foot
Kingda Ka at Six Flags in Jackson, New Jersey
is arguably (please, argue in the comments)
the best roller coaster on Earth, though Julia
swears by the Millennium Force at Cedar Point.
There's a lot of physics involved with designing
a coaster: potential energy on the hills,
kinetic energy on the drops and acceleration,
g-forces, apparent weight, and so on on the
loops and turns.
In the end though, you don't need to grasp
physics to build a good coaster -- you just
need to understand physiology.
Coasters are basically trains that use those
forces to manipulate your inner ear, internal
organs, and other senses to mess with your
brain chemistry.
These drops, jerks and free-floating gravity
trips are meant to give you a whiff of fear,
without making you feel in any real danger.
Its the same kind of fear that you get from
haunted houses, and extreme-sports activities
like skydiving.
Some people are thrill seekers, they get a
natural high from the brain chemicals released
when they encounter the fight-or-flight response.
When our ancient brains believe there's a
danger to our body -- even if there isn't
REAL danger -- our amygdala triggers releasing
a host of chemicals to prep our bodies to
literally fight for our lives or escape (i.e.
fight-or-fight).
As the brain is constantly sucking in information,
it can assess risk and flip this response
in an instant.
That causes a release of dopamine, serotonin,
adrenaline and oxytocin to help hone the mind,
focus the senses and prepare the body for
action.
Of course… then… no action comes.
The roller coaster ends and you're left with
the aftermath of all those chemicals surging
through your body.
Your hands are shaking, you're sweating, and
you probably have a feeling of euphoria.
Some of you might have noticed oxytocin slipped
in there with the fairly predictable cocktail
of chemicals.
When the body is scared we release oxytocin.
It's commonly called the "love hormone" but
it's more accurately a bonding hormone.
It helps specific memories stick in our memories
-- like which things are dangerous, or which
people help in times of high-stress.
When we come down from that fear; like after
a roller coaster ride; we perceive all these
things and end up laughing from the euphoria,
and feeling closer to those who experienced
it with us.